having spent most of my life living in
Los Angeles I'm now the opinion that it
can be an interesting place to visit if
you know where to go and what to look
for but that I wouldn't want to live
there
after visiting it again I now feel the
same way about the Los Santos of GTA
online there are some great moments to
be had but they can be difficult or
impossible to access they lack any kind
of coherence structure and they're prone
to all kinds of hang-ups and mishaps if
you want to enjoy GTA online you have to
be willing to let go of any sort of
desire for control and just go with the
flow whether it'll take you someplace
wonderful or some place infuriating is
anyone's guess
using money from the stimulus package
that Rockstar gave players who access
the game in October of last year I
bought myself a swanky penthouse
apartment with pretty art on the walls
and a gorgeous view of the city below
but what's the point of such material
wealth in a world as bleak as that of
Grand Theft Auto online you're still as
vulnerable as any other soul unfortunate
enough to be living on these violent
streets at least in single-player GTA
there's a story structure if you want it
offering a larger goal to work toward in
GTA online there's no greater purpose to
fight for and you share the world with
other people who also have nothing
meaningful to strive for so the result
is a nihilistic world in which life is
dirt cheap with players constantly
gunning each other down for no reason
whatsoever if there's a meaning to be
found in Grand Theft Auto online it's in
the way that through depicting a society
with no opportunities to do anything
constructive or meaningful it
underscores the things in our world that
actually are meaningful sometimes you
might be going about your business
trying to steal a car for Simeon or
maybe just go buy some new clothes
but instead you get stuck in a loop of
getting murdered respawning and getting
murdered again you can turn on passive
mode so that other players can gun you
down but you can still be a victim of
vehicular manslaughter
violence breeds violence you end up
seeing any nearby player as a threat and
plot your weapon ready to gun them down
before they gun you down it becomes an
unending cycle of pointless slaughter
that pulls you away from what you'd
rather be doing
there are opportunities to escape the
insanity of unstructured life on the
streets by hopping into races missions
or other activities but you might try to
launch one of these only to find that no
other players will join you preventing
you from having the GTA online
experience you want to have you can also
wait for invites to activities from
other players or use the quick job
option to hop right into an activity
with other players but you don't know if
the activity you'll be tossed into will
be a well-designed
race created by Rockstar or a sloppy
event tossed together by another player
still there's enough of a chance that
you'll have a great experience that it's
worth the gamble time and time again the
gameplay and the setting and the music
of Grand Theft Auto online combine to
lend your car chases and shootouts and
other in-game actions the look and feel
of something out of a cinematic crime
classic and there are moments of
tranquility - like when you just take a
leisurely Drive or parachute over the
Alamo see Grand Theft Auto online
greatest assets are still it's
incredible setting and soundtrack while
Santos is a city that's ugly and
beautiful in the way that real lived in
cities are ugly and beautiful but Grand
Theft Auto online performance sometimes
interferes with your appreciation of its
best qualities you might be caught up in
the heat of the moment racing against
other players as a great song plays on
the radio only to have the game hitch up
for several seconds Grand Theft Auto
online is never a boring game I never
know quite what the next five minutes
will bring and in any given moment I
might be thrilled or frustrated or both
but I'm always engaged but because
everything is so chaotic and so
disjointed I can only spend a little
time in its world before I need to leave
Los Santos behind and return to a place
where I feel like my actions might
actually mean something